it's been 2 190 days Rihanna we waited
Sears since the nine-time Grammy winner
Rihanna is with everybody
the fans just predicted
Rihanna teases her upcoming Super Bowl
halftime performance
and sorry Riri but we can't shh because
the whole thing has us so excited it's
something that I feel like my fans
really really want Apple music just
dropped a trailer featuring Rihanna
posing it up in a neon yellow coat and
in the clip some of the headlines that
have been surrounding her highly
anticipated performance it's been 2 190
days dude Rihanna we waited it's been
over six year since the nine-time Grammy
winner
but all the noise is silenced when the
spotlight hits the Grammy winner in a
super dramatic moment
does anyone else have Goosebumps over
their entire body re-confirmed she'll
headline the halftime show on February
12th back in September on Instagram
making her long-awaited return to the
stage six years after releasing her last
studio album anti
[Applause]
is the Super Bowl halftime show
something that you would be willing to
entertain if Ashley is my first time
hearing about the Super Bowl since last
Super Bowl girl I still got an album
back in 2020 Riri played koi about a
potential Super Bowl performance and
teased that when she does drop new music
it'll be worth the wait I'm always
working on music when it happens it's
going to be worth it I'm not just gonna
put it out just because people are
waiting like and last year shortly after
we announced she was expecting her first
baby with ASAP Rocky she hinted that new
music isn't far away do you think this
stage in your life is going to inspire
new music oh gosh yes you're still gonna
get music from me maybe a lullaby I can
see you and ASAP dropping Demos in the
studio oh my goodness not a lullaby my
family kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby well after news broke that
Reed was headed to the Super Bowl uh
source told ET that the Stars aligned
and it's the right time for the 34 year
old Fenty founder to take the stage
again adding that she'll give it one
thousand percent well you have to and
when ET was with Rihanna in November the
singer who welcomed her baby boy in May
teased what we can expect I can't
believe I even said yes but no but you
know like it was one of those sorry it
was one of those things that like even
when I announced it I thought it was
like okay I can't take it back now it's
like not final yeah I can't believe I
just what did I just get myself into
because the Super Bowl is one of the
biggest stages in the world yeah it's an
Entertainer's dream to be on a stage
like that but it's nerve-wracking you
want to get it right you know
everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you yeah and I
want I want to get it right so one of
the challenge that I was willing to
accept well being a new mom nothing
would have gotten me out the house if it
wasn't a challenge like that it's been
2190 days dude Rihanna we waited
six years since the nine-time Grammy
winner everybody is
[Music]